robin lord taylor stop by our studios
if you don't watch the tv show gotham
just take it from me the guys hello
there wow look at you it's so weird to
see you like as a normal person
you know what i mean
like wow that's you huh yeah i know wow
i know i know i can't believe that's you
it's the physical transformation is like
half the character do you have to cut
your hair as penguin or like you have to
yeah it's not my hair anymore i'm
naturally blonde oh cute
like are you kidding me every two and a
half weeks wow wow how did you get that
part did you have to audition like 20
000 times no it was insane so i it was
it was pilot season right and this was
one of the first ones that came out and
they didn't tell me what the job was so
i just went in they wrote a fake scene
with fake characters you're kidding why
can't you know what the job is well
because i think kind of what they wanted
is that they wanted something they
didn't want people to come in and do
like the idea of the people yeah right
exactly yeah they wanted their own thing
yeah to happen and so i think that was a
lot of it and they were somehow able to
envision you as the penguin yeah it's
insane which is weird because in the
comic book they'd always draw the
penguin as a little fat guy right right
and no one ever imagined them as a young
man really i don't remember any of the
comics because i've read every one of
those comics yeah yeah totally yeah it's
weird it's crazy and then he call you up
what like a week or two later and say
hey you're gonna be the penguin in
gotham it was i've never had an audition
that went that easily like i i went on
tape i did it once do you remember what
the scene was yeah it was it was like
some character i think his name was paul
were you even a villain in the in the
scene in the scene yeah
yeah it was kind of like he uh he was
like shaking down some like mafioso guy
and and trying to get the the mafia guy
to do him a solid and the mafia guy is
like you know piss off who are you and
then he's like oh by the way i have your
daughter uh tied up in the back or
something like that it's amazing they
can do like one read through
and know you're the guy
yeah i mean i think you're really
[ __ ] awesome
you know because you didn't play it like
you didn't go over the top with it which
i think was a wise decision if you're on
a superhero show everyone and especially
if you're playing a villain
we're all writing in the wake of heath
ledger i mean like what he did was just
he just broke the thing the mold into a
million pieces you know and then that's
that's what we're all just trying to win
when they aspire to you know when they
told you that the part you got was
gotham and you were going to be the
penguin
do you go back and were you a comic book
fan i i was i mean i i didn't i wasn't
like i had a neighbor who was very much
into them and so you know i would read
them with him but i wasn't as much i was
reading mad magazine like crazy that
that was kind of my thing see i think
that's why you're doing such a good job
that in a way you weren't a super fan
like you're just bringing an actor's
point of view to this guy who's a mess
and then yeah and you know and you have
some empathy with him yeah it's kind of
it's kind of cool and he's not
one-dimensional you kind of like him and
you hate him right you know it's kind of
it's really good well that's kind of the
goal and also but i have to say though
like when i got it i was like you know
of course i grew up watching the adam
west series i watched it every day after
elementary school and then all of the
batman movies especially batman returns
i was obsessed with you know this was
like when it came out on cinemax and you
just watched it
so when you get the party you go back
and watch heath ledger and all these
guys do you go out and rent every
superhero movie just yeah people brought
to it absolutely yeah definitely and
like you know like yeah i just recently
watched batman returns again and danny
devito is just fantastic he's fabulous
how much makeup you got to do for that
room it's like 50 minutes of makeup
50. yeah yeah they glue a prosthetic on
their nose yeah and it's just it's
really small it's just like a bump in
the tip and then and then uh and then
there's like airbrushing and then they
paint my teeth and my nails like all
kind of like like nasty slimy [ __ ]
yeah and so uh yeah and so uh so that's
it and then there's like 35 minutes for
hair and then another like maybe 10 20
minutes of work you're one of those
actors that like stays in character
during
no you don't do any of that
nothing against people you're not a
daniel day lewis no but also that's the
thing is like i couldn't imagine like
doing nine months of just being like in
you mean
i don't have to call you penguins
at the craft services yeah right and i'm
just like penguins sitting there like
making shitty faces
no no way and that's the other two is
like people ask me often like because
you know i have that limp in the show
and they're like they're like do you
ever find yourself doing the limp when
you're not on set i'm like are you nuts
no i heard you put like glass in your
shoes
well there was one day where i forgot
the lamp it was a big scene with the
it's like when i first come back to
gotham city in season one and uh and i
walk off the bus we're in chinatown and
there's like extras running around it's
like july it sucks and i walk off and i
like i'm like oh i'm home and then i
walk away and then i get back onto the
bus or i get back to my chair or
whatever and i'm like i forgot i forgot
to limp i forgot the limb completely did
no one pick that up in the production
you think that someone would but there's
somebody who has a job who sits there
and watches other [ __ ] like that exactly
you're walking around normally the funny
thing is she came and she came up to me
earlier that day because the previous
day that i shot the previous episode
i've forgotten again and i had to be
reminded she came up to me at the start
of the day and she was like she was like
i i've been told that sometimes you
forget the limp and i just want you to
know that i'm looking out for you
yeah and so i was like oh i got this and
then i forget the limp and i'm the one
who has to go back and be like in your
shoe in order to remember so i had a
bottle like a water bottle cap like like
one of these like you know the hearts
the flat side up so i did that for a
while and then after you know maybe mid
season second season i was like you know
this okay i think i got this we i i
remember the lamp
i downgraded to uh 50 cents so i have
two quarters and you feel that yeah
totally it's it's actually really it's
it's nice because it's just like it's an
old acting trick like from like stella
adler who was like you know you know she
was like back in the day and like you
know she was like teaching someone i
think it was like hat on a hot tim roof
where you know he has the broken leg or
whatever she's like you got a broken leg
put a rock in your shoe make it real for
yourself you know it's kind of nice you
know it's like and that's about an
acting technique it's about his method
as i guess yeah